foreign
[Music]
jets flying through the air really
really quick make it really hard to
figure out a camera track and so we had
to utilize GPS data from the actual
camera planes in combination with USGS
topographical data to actually plot out
various points and then rework our light
rigs to be able to actually properly
coordinate things as Jets moving as fast
as they do actually hit curvature that
changes Lighting in extremely subtle
ways
the special effects Department build for
bespoke high performance Batmobiles and
each version of the vehicle was
engineered and constructed for a
specific purpose and they were all built
from scratch because each Batmobile was
kind of custom tailored for a specific
job they didn't all fit the design spec
exactly for example the jumping
Batmobile once it hit the ground and it
stood back up on that long throw
suspension you know it looked like the
Daddy Long Legs version of the Batmobile
at a certain point had to take over and
replace that along with the wet ground
and the fire reflecting off the water
smoke was something that we wanted to
keep open for the audience to figure out
what this is at the same time I always
thought of it as a sort of announcement
of the creatures whether it's their
smell or their pollution when you see a
big cloud wave coming you know there's
something bad behind it
that sequence was so sensitive to
contrast whether you see him or not and
so we actually had to render those shots
twice one pass with the machines and
then one without and we sort of
integrating did a life mixing in DaVinci
resolved
50 if not more of our sets did have a
water feature of some kind
well like Craig kind of chat to the
integration between Dan sudix massive
Rigs and then the islands work and
combining those two worlds dance Riggs
gave us a foundation that was Rock
Steady everything possible that was safe
but safe is not what you want so
everything needed augmentation a layer
on top basically the whole front layer
of it
well we switched to a stereo head rig we
had been using on the first film a
single camera but the cameras were
lightweight enough that we could go with
stereo but really the key was the facial
system we put everything into a neural
network and the beauty of that is when
you're changing from pose to pose every
point on the face understands what every
other point on the face should be doing
they took him
foreign